can you hear me i can hear you my mic
doesn't work anyway um what i was saying
was uh lisa kudrow is very close to you
that's like sister yes and you you i can
talk about lisa lisa is in the business
and we know her from friends because of
you i think yes
well when you have a story
what happened was uh no i we
um
i lived in encino and then we moved to
tarzana
wow see when i was in fifth grade and
that's when i met jeff paul
and he knows david kudrow who was in our
class lisa's older brother and david and
i became very good friends
and um jeff you know and there was uh
kevin brooks and bernie chase jeff knows
all these people yeah but nobody
listening does so you if you want to
name the whole kevin was a big dj up in
santa barbara anyway so so
so david was um
we we i met him in fifth grade and then
we became friends in sixth grade like
best friends so i remember he brought me
to his house
and he kept saying you have to meet my
little sister lisa and i was 11 and lisa
was uh
five
and i remember going to his house and he
goes lisa and he goes she speaks spanish
too and and and she was sitting in a
tiny little chair watching tv she was my
sister uh
lisa he goes is my friend john say hi
and she turned she was hello hola and
she was so she looked like a miniature
dave she was the cutest little thing
and um so i and i would spend all all my
life you know at their house so his
parents became like my parents and his
sis older sister uh helene and lisa
we were 12 we both had just sisters so
we go we'll be brothers we really want
to brothers so they're my family you
know i grew up with them so anyway
i was in college um i was 20 and i came
home and lisa was 14 at the time and she
was i was a drama major at uc irvine and
she said oh um you're studying acting
what's that like so i would talk to her
about it and i never really talked to
her much because she was so much younger
and like you know they're kids she'd be
in david's room and dave would go get
out you know they'd fight
and i would talk to her about it she
asked me questions i said david you know
your sister lisa is really fun to talk
to she's really smart
and i knew her but we never talked about
and then i got her a book called uh
auditioned by michael shirtleff and i to
lisa i said to my fellow thespian you
know good luck you're acting and then um
when i got
i was on saturday night live i got it in
85 and lisa was in new york and now
she's like about 22 or 23. she was i do
some characters i visit her and she did
it and then one day she she called me
she said hey listen i want to um i want
to go into acting what should i do so i
said well go to the groundlings theater
that's like i learned the most there so
and i go if anyone gives you a hard time
let me know you know i'll
i'll
you know [ __ ] knock them out you
really someone else's always been
violent so so well anyway
well they were weird people there and
there was some nuts and i said if anyone
gives you a hard time let me know so
anyway but after that she did it you
know she really did it on her own and
then sometimes she called me out three
times she'd asked me for advice on
something in acting she was what are you
thinking well i think you should do this
she goes oh well i was thinking maybe i
would do this and then this
and every every time she told me what
she wanted to do and i'd say
no you know what you're right that's
better do that that's smarter every time
and anyway and then you know she ended
up teaching there and she got um she she
she did it on her own though she got
cast on um
was it mad fraser fraser and then they
recast her and then she got friends you
know and she was on uh mad about you but
she did it on her own it took her like
10 years
and she does good are you still close to
her now yeah it's like my sister and
then and then when when um
i'd watch her on friend zone i said
and i knew her sister a lot of what she
did i go i knew i knew because i go up
with her family she's imitating her
older sister helene a lot oh really and
i said you're i go i want you you're
doing the holy [ __ ] don't tell anyone
john james
oh yeah i knew because i you know
their family i go there and she told you
not to tell anyone yeah i go that's
elaine she's doing was that private was
that private information now the show's
over who gives a crap
but a lot of her humor was imitating
helene um but both of us
talked about david and david who's a if
you need a neurologist he's fantastic
david's really really funny and a lot
both of us you know
we're influenced by him you know you're
with your best friend you start talking
like him and doing stuff and
and um
he never went and we said we no lisa and
i both said david could do this he would
do voi any accent
very funny but he didn't want to do it
[Music]